Mark: Hello everybody my name is...
Ethan: Why?
[Mark:] ...Markiplier, and welcome to the "Arrow Dodge Challenge".
We are uncomfortably close because we love you and also because this camera seems to be having some problems.
But either way we are going to be doing the "Arrow Dodge Challenge".
We got done with the water bottle flip
challenge and it was a lot of fun we had
an arrow component but not a dodge
component so we're going to take turns
shooting at each other up on the stage
over there which is currently empty. Show
the stage.
*crickets*
Yup it's empty alright. [Ethan: What a good stage] What a
good stage. That is the shooting range
where we'll be dying. But for every arrow
that does not kill us *whispers* meaning we don't
get hit *normal voice* we get a point.
Whoever has the most points at the end
wins and then we'll figure something
else out over go along ok break. Team!
You get a point
Wade: Yay
Mark: That silent Tyler.
Alright so we're gonna do rock paper scissors
to see who goes first. Who wants to go?
I guess it's us three then, and ok
rock-paper-scissors shoot. Well I...
Ethan: you're not going first
Mark: Not going first that's for damn sure
Wade: Hi Bob .
Ethan: Hi Bob.
Bob: Alright I'll join.
* ethan grunting*
Bob: Wow okay.
Ethan: Okay. *"ha"'s in quick succession*
Ethan: I go first
Wade: No scissors cuts... talc [Ethan: what the f] Mark: The reason
Tyler is up there is because he didn't get
a single arrow shot at him in the last challenge
so we're just going to go for him
Mark: That's backwards, that's back- this is off to a bad start
Ethan: Yep
Ethan: Here we go. Are we ready?
Mark: Yes
Ethan: All right
Ethan: You know what Tyler did to your family? Killed em all.
Bob: Let's go right in the ass [Mark: right in]
Bob: Got ya bitch x2
Tyler: nice shot
Ethan: right in butt the right in the faeces
Mark: nice shot
Everyone: right in the ass [Ethan: gotcha]
Mark *in weird voice*: Right in the ass x2
Ethan: Shit!
Bob: I'm going right for the dick this time
Mark: He's asking for it. You can see by the
way he's dressed.
He's asking for it
Wade: No.
Mark: Whyyyyyy?
Wade: Is that a blooper? Mark: Whyyyy? x 2 [Ethan: Bob]
Ethan: Bob
Bob: Hey it was bound to happen
Mark: No it wasn't
Tyler: They hit me twice
Mark: Yeah you got hit twice
Ethan: Any last words?
Mark: Ah man your mom's so hot
Ethan: Shit
Mark: Wade you know, I always thought you were a handsome devil
[Wade: I know] Mark: Now that I see, I see you're
fuck ugly as fuck
Wade: Yeah you better be
careful what you say
Wade: Whoa that went high
Ethan: Goddammit! We're not going to have any arrows left *all laugh*
Bob: Drop shot
Bob: Oh I thought you were going to jump back that way Mark: Nope
Mark: Yipp-hoo
Ethan: You almost jumped into that one.
Mark: I had to stop myself hard, woo
Tyler: So it comes down to me, to break the tie.
Mark: YAY
Mark: Oh man okay so I made it with just two hits
Ethan: How spry are you, Wade?
Wade: We'll find out
Bob: He's not very spry
Bob: Tyler's going full angry
Mark: Alright. I love you. You're a handsome devil Wade: And?
Mark: And you have lovely hair.
Wade: Thank you
Mark: And, uh, frankly
you are just- *everyone laughs*
Bob: You're out!
Mark: Goddammit, he's got me guys.
Another one of our our team come in.
Bob: Hahahaha dodgeball
Ethan: That was nice
Wade: I don't know what that counts as
Tyler: No you got hit.
Bob: That's what that counts as
Mark: if you catch it with your-uh- your teeth maybe
Wade: *grunts*
Bob: Yeah try and catch it with your teeth [Wade: AH] that sounds fun
*Nope*
*glass shatters*
Bob: Fucking Christ
Bob: Jesus dammit!
Mark: *whispers* That broke something
Tyler: That broke something
Bob: God!
Mark: Ok, so we accidentally broke the
neighbors lamp which is great but he's
super nice
we offered to pay for it he was like oh
no it's fine so if Weston's over there
hi and thank you for being nice
we'll finish this stuff and try not to
break anything else *dramatic pause*  BOB! that's the second one
Tyler and Mark: that's the second one over the fence [Bob: nah I didn't do it]
Mark: oh? *whispers* we've got video evidence
Mark: ok we're getting back into it, Wade's
still up there, he's not off the block
Wade: I can't see anything the glares gotten so
much worse then when I was here before
Mark: Wade you are a shining example of
everything wrong with society [Wade:what?] you have
had a lack of  -ohhhhhh *giggles*
Ethan: you have escaped death, so far
Well, not really that's a lie
from me [Tyler: you need to pull it back further]  well I don't wanna
destroy him
All: OHHHHHHH
Mark: wow
Bob: he switched directions, immediately
Wade: yeah, and I caught the one I got hit by
Mark: Eh
Mark: yeah that was pretty good *sounds of agreement*
Mark: I think Wade's in the lead
Ethan: i will go [Tyler: he hasn't hit anybody though
Mark: ok Wade you got to hit people
Mark: Alright we got a small target coming up here
Ethan:oh you cannot see all
Ethan: oh this is so scary... Shit I can't see
Everyone: ohhhhhh
Tyler: one hit
Ethan: I've lost an arm oh no Mark: no you stick that arm
back out there Ethan: and stick it back out?
I'm afraid please don't go full power Tyler
Ethan: Please! Spare me!
Ethan: wow
Ethan: That close to me
Ethan: Bob, you're a nice guy
Bob: no
*everyone cheers*
Mark: why were you moving when I wasn't even doing anything [Ethan: *in anguish* I don't know!]
Ethan: why am I spending my energy like that?
*all cheer*
Tyler: Ready big boy?
Ethan: can you not? Can you not do it super hard?
Ethan: Why are you pulling it back so much?!
Ethan: It got my butt on the way back
Ethan: the big boy is back on campus
Ethan: *thrust* whatcha got?
Mark: I'm very sorry Ethan, I think Tyler really wants to get you this time
Ethan: I! Just don't- just don't do it super hard. TYLER
Ethan: Please
Bob: ohhh
Tyler: it slipped from my hand *murmurs about hands*
Mark: ooh nooo x 2   Bob: Oh no
Ethan: is that everybody? [Wade: uh oh]
Ethan: you don't get another one!
Ethan: you don't get a mulligan this is not golf [Bob: yeah! A mulligan]
Bob: that's a great idea [Ethan: no! No mulligans! HELP ME!!!]
Ethan: ah, ohh. That stung
Ethan: OK!
Tyler: HE WASN'T EVEN LOOKING AND YOU MISSED BY THAT MUCH!
Wade: that much
Mark: It was like that much
Ethan: Bob, you're aiming, you're aiming low there, pal
Ethan: You are-
Mark: How many times did you get hit
Ethan: Twice?
*murmurs of disagreement*
Tyler: you got hit four times [Mark: oh we got a present, thank you!
Ethan: So I got hit a lot but Mark: we'll count it back
Mark: but you're definitely in the lead
for being hit
Ethan: It's a lot more scary than you think
Mark: ready?
Bob: sure
Mark: all right
Ethan: are you excited?
Bob: no.
Tyler: are you excited for when I shoot?
Bob: no
Mark: ooh almost
Ethan: That's one hit!
Bob: take it easy man
Tyler: I'm sorry, Bob
Mark: you don't have to do it [Ethan: isn't he intimidating??]
Bob: you can not shoot as hard as possible
Wade: he just
Wade: steps up and it's scary
Bob: Goddammit
*the group Oooo"s
Ethan: you weren't very nice to me so I'm not going to be very nice to you [Bob: I hit you once in the foot]
*group laughs*
Ethan: We don't have to talk about what you did
Ethan: it was what your intentions were
Ethan: My intentions, are the same
All: WOAH
Bob: I got  some tricks up my sleeve
Mark: If you want to tie, you have to hit him
I've got to hit this [Wade: I'm still the best dodger]
Ethan: If I don't get this i lose then I get
hit with a lotta arrows [Mark: A lot]
Ethan: I gotta channel my energy
*all laugh uproariously*
Mark: No ethan, no ethan
Wade: I think even if he gets a hit, it's a disqualification Ethan: I'm not even trying to
fuck up
Mark: were you trying before is
that your excuse here Ethan: no!
Ethan: bleugh. *Coughs*
Mark: great video
Wade: please don't lower the bow, you're gonna screw it up again
just aim
Ethan: my fingers really hurt
Bob: Oh my god Wade: you can't hold it for long Bob
Tyler: That was so bad!
Ethan: it slipped out of my fingers
Tyler: it didn't even get down course [Mark: so bad]
Bob: Put on the mask   Wade: if you can't make that shot *chorus of put on the mask*
Mark: so e-tan lost because I don't know what
happened do a statistical analysis of
what the hell happened
Tyler: he's the smallest target *agreement*
Bob: uh huh, uh huh I'm calculating
Mark: what happened
Tyler: and he got
hit the most
Mark: what happened out there?
Ethan: I'm the smallest target i'm probably the
most spry person here
and I lost
Mark: you used to be- you
didn't even take an opportunity to do a backflip
Ethan: I know! Because why would I?
Mark: Alright, whatever, we're all gonna shoot him so get up there
Ethan: I want to be wearing a cup
Mark: ok this looks great Ethan: this does not look
great I don't know what you're talking
about this looks horrible
Mark: we're not going to shoot everyone just
hold your bows like up and ready
Ethan: This is the most intimidating thing
Mark: annnnnnnnnd [Ethan proceeds to squeal in fear]
*resounding chorus of no's*
Mark: Up, up [Ethan: I hate it!] up and
Mark: Fire at will.
Mark: you're supposed to dodge, you're supposed to dodge
Tyler: you ARE supposed to dodge
Ethan: I can't dodge these, there's too many of em'
Ethan: this is not fun, this is a horrible
time, this is a horrible time! Please stop!
Mark: aren't you glad you moved to LA? [Ethan: PLEASE STOP]
Ethan: stop, why did I move here?
Mark: annnnnd
Mark: LOOSE
*Ethan shrieks* *all laugh*
Tyler: ONE MORE ROUND Ethan: I wanna go home
Wade: you know I think we should redo this shot
Ethan: NO! Mark: yeah I think I need a better thumbnai
Tyler: yeah the camera stopped Mark: we better re-do all of this
Ethan: NO-HO-HO-HO
Ethan: Please! Stop
Tyler: FIRE!
*Ethan makes sounds of pain and relief*
Bob: Mark, don't you get a fourth shot?
All: oh yeah Tyler: you do! Bob: Mark gets the final shot
Ethan: why are you going so close
Mark: Get on your knees and turn around x 3  [Ethan: I hate this x 3]
Darkiplier: guys don't look, don't look at this one Ethan:* screams*
Mark: do you want it through the heart, or through the head [Ethan: I DON'T KNOW]
Mark: Heart or head? Ethan: AH! My... heeeaart?
Bob: Oh my god, that thud
Mark: WOAH, who did that??
Tyler: That was Wade
Ethan: Wade? You did not get a fourth shot! [Wade: I fired way over there] Firing squad, now!
Mark: So anyway, that was the arrow dodge challenge
Thank you everybody so much for watching
Thank you everybody for participating- uh
The score is *hurling noise* to *bleugh*
The winner being *Winston* and the loser being- oh, it's Ethan *all laugh*
Ethan: it's me x 2 Mark: We know
Wade: Dodge champion
Mark: Thank you everybody so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next video
Buh bye
Mark: Geeze
Ethan: what happened? where did those come from?
Mark: *in soft voice* what happened Frobo?
[All: Sam, Sam Sam]
Wade: I actually didn't see him throw those either so that made me scared
Ethan: it was like high from the sky [Wade: I didn't see your arm
move, it was just all of a sudden raining
Mark: an arrow to block out the sky
I thought the neighbor was getting revenge
*All laugh*